[Música]
i
mientras traductor y dirigida otra otra
otra crítica otros pero hay crítica
contra otros dos ministros ultranza y
dirigido contra un drama dirigido a otra
pero a ti ni te gusta o no
y ahora
[Música]
puesto
y
es también una balanza a los corazones
tiempo
sólo hay uno
y si hay otro pide esto me llena
[Música]
hay unos días más
si hay otro pide tu venganza
ya pegó un tiro a la calle la reina
confianza en el hombre nunca más te
nunca la tenga hermana no la tenga yo
pego un tiro al aire y cayó
como yo
i
[Música]
y hoy
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
hola
[Música]
y ese niño marinero que se quiere ir al
puerto puerto del andalucía el puerto de
santa maría y ese niño marinero que se
quiere ir a puerto puerto de santa lucía
el puerto de santa maría
[Música]
benito
a la vida ahora
[Música]
todo
i
no
[Música]
[Aplausos]